gérer les candidats aux élections
législatives anticipées du 12 juin
jusqu'à minuit pour déposer leur
candidature une partie de l'opposition
déterminée à boycotter ces élections
pourrait faire marche arrière si aucun
candidat de l'opposition de déposer sa
candidature alors le futur parlement
risque très fortement de ressembler à
l'ancien port abdallah militant
politique et médecins ces élections ne
sont qu'une mise en scène écouter le son
dans une situation en algérie
host régime le régime organise les
élections après les autres mais on a vu
comment on se sent passer par exemple le
référendum constitutionnel le 1er
novembre sous les 25 millions
d'électeurs seuls 3,7 en beauté me et
sur l'ensemble de jeu de ceux qui se
sont déplacés
il ya eu 23 % de la population qui s'est
déplacé donc c'est fiasco total
la vie politique en algérie n'est qu'une
façade les parties sont désignés par les
services
les élections sont organisées par les
services et les résultats sont connus
d'avancé